what's the deal y'all this is not Little
Fizz this is not Cleo Thomas this is big
yellow Hill to log the [ __ ] with
the two braids french braids we gonna
gang bang gang slang Chain Swing Lane
change shout out to my boy bootleg Kev
this is the podcast this is the best
interview make sure that you tap into
this [ __ ] right now yeah
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here my guy yellow Hill what's the word
man how you doing I'm good man what's
cracking it's good to see you bro well I
was gonna say how was the holiday but
you did not celebrate Thanksgiving we
don't celebrate Thanksgiving man proud
Native Americans man I might sneak a
little turkey and ham here and there but
that's about it I mean who really
celebrates Thanksgiving though I feel
like it's really just eating yeah yeah
it's like it's like Christmas right like
I'm an atheist but I celebrate Christmas
because I I give my kids presents and my
wife likes a tree and [ __ ] and it's
really not about baby Jesus yeah for me
you like Santa Claus and [ __ ] too right
yeah Santa Claus is obviously a
fictional character
yeah no for sure I feel the same when I
was younger my mother alert
in case there's a [ __ ] eight-year-old
watching the Yoho interview oh [ __ ]
Santa's not real Santa's not real no
Santa's real to all the kids watching
Santa's real the elves are real the
North Pole the South Pole [ __ ] don't let
them lie to you
oh [ __ ] oh man now my son's like nine
and he'd been asking me [ __ ] like I feel
like he's starting to catch on because
we went to yeah he got a PC for his uh
Christmas present last year yeah and I
bought it at Best Buy but he thinks
Santa got it for him oh yeah so that
[ __ ] started tripping and so like three
days ago four days ago I took him to
Best Buy because I have the warranty and
he looked at me while we were standing
in line and he said why are we here if
Santa got me this yeah yeah I was like a
Santa got Best Buy warranties
yeah well at a certain age at like maybe
13 or 14 I think I really discovered
that a fat [ __ ] in a red suit and a
[ __ ] big ass mustache and a beard was
not sliding down any chimney and if he
was he's probably a pedophile he's a
criminal that happened oh [ __ ] like
seriously if you woke up in the middle
of the night and there was a fat guy in
a red coat with a hobby kind of alarmed
yeah you'd have to call the police oh
yeah no Intruder I might grab my grab a
little shotgun get that [ __ ] out of
here what is your uh what Native uh
tribe are you I was Calientes hot water
Indians in Palm Springs [ __ ] yeah I've
seen that [ __ ] before yeah I feel like
while I'm while I'm over there I see
that like on signs yeah yeah is that
like who has the casinos out there there
are casinos as a reservation it's just a
whole little it's a whole different
world bro it's crazy it's like almost
going back in time to like 18 17 16 like
all those old years centuries ago so in
AZ we have a I grew up around a lot of
natives uh like the navajos and there's
tons of tribes in Arizona
um and um their casinos you can't drink
or Gamble
in the casino that your own tribe owns
is it like a pachang like what's the
casino called there's a bunch there's
like Casino Arizona yes Talking Stick
there's a bunch but like yeah there's
like a rule that like you can't drink or
gamble yeah if you're uh Native at the
casino because it's like they look like
it's customary what's like bad for the
for their people sure sure
um but between different native tribes
and like Native American Indians there's
always just different you know there's
different things that you can and can't
do I feel like there's like Cherokee
navajos and then you have the patches
there's different morals and principles
that differ all of them just possess but
as far as patches are just the ganks
they're like the [ __ ]
yeah they're like you know they're
they're like the big you them [ __ ]
will hop out bam big trucks they don't
smoke shout out to the Apaches yeah
[ __ ] okay so you're like like what is
your racial you're a racially ambiguous
I'm everywhere bro if you see me you're
like this [ __ ] is just [ __ ] just
everything yeah so what is everything
it's crazy that's you know I love you're
doing 23andMe I love to keep the CR I
love to create the mysticism I love that
show you're Mexican as well yeah I'm
Mexican too Mexican Mexican black Native
American wow and I think I got you know
you know when you do the little
ancestry.com [ __ ] got some Nigerian
some Spaniard in them but you know so
you did [ __ ] can't really count that
yeah I did that yeah I just ordered some
for Black Friday I ordered the test kit
you did yeah you're gonna find out you
black [ __ ] seventy percent I'm gonna
find it it's just albino I'm ex I'm as
white as I thought I was
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] yeah so because you're you are
one of the few La artists who can like
kind of navigate around like a bunch of
different pockets of this seen out here
like I see you doing a record with like
Swifty blue and it's like not out of the
blue and then you could work with you
know I mean you're obviously a [ __ ] so
there's that you know what I mean so
yeah
um yeah I feel like you might be the
only guy that's kind of like in that
lane and kind of just Diversified I can
go anywhere yeah yeah I feel you is that
fair do you feel that way I love that
that's amazing I [ __ ] with that I don't
want to just be in a pocket or in a
boxing shirt that's fair you know what
I'm saying yeah you've I feel like since
the first time I met you I remember uh I
want to say Nema told me about you like
maybe a year and a half ago or so yeah
when you first signed right
um you've just been working man going in
Non-Stop going in how many projects have
you dropped in the last like two years
oh I want to say maybe
13. [ __ ]
13 projects in the last two years you
know I got some [ __ ] I got a rock
project I'm working on it's just you got
to just keep flooding you never know
what what pocket everybody's gonna
really appreciate and I love everything
yeah and like your fan bases like you
see the the growth man yeah what do you
think because like I feel like
you know there's a lot of people who can
make great music but it's kind of hard
to like convert those into like fans or
people who people might follow you but
like how do you get them to spend money
with you how do you get them to like
really buy into what you're doing to
where you're not just having followers
you have people who actually support you
for one you have to be a communicator
and you have to be somebody that speaks
you have to be somebody that people can
mesh well with see it's easy for me to
like maybe come up to this podcast show
say I had like a link up in my head
right a bunch of face tats and my
attitude and my personality was terrible
right right they have fans for that but
then when you really like sit down with
yourself and you discuss who you are and
you do these interviews like the bootleg
Kev podcast you go and do this [ __ ]
hot 97 [ __ ] you do whatever no jumper
they get to really know who you are and
they fall in love with you you know what
I'm saying you just keep it real and
authentic that's how I feel like I've
got my cult following I mean I got
people that got my face tatted
everywhere you know I feel like not just
based on my music but based on my
character and who I am and how I'm so
relatable and I'm not a fake ass [ __ ]
wow yes how many people have do you have
like a count like uh how many people
have your face tattooed on their body I
would say
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick you already know man our partners
in my bookie they be holding me down
when it comes to all the money I'll be
making on gambling on these
[ __ ] Sports man that's right
they're your sports betting Haven all
right and it is Thanksgiving week big
games coming up uh yo we got the uh
Cowboys obviously playing the Giants
Vikings versus the Patriots Bills vs
Lions I think the bills are going to
absolutely
destroy the Lions uh actually you know
you could put together a nice little
three team parlay on Thanksgiving so
while you're watching turkey you can
watch some football and you can win some
[ __ ] money all right but this is the
most important part when you go to my
bookie go to my bookie right now
mybookie.ag
sign up for a new account use the promo
code bootleg
and guess what they will match your
first deposit up to a thousand dollars
so let's say Thanksgiving you're like
you know what I'm trying to get in on
some of this action that's cool sign up
in my bookie put in two three hundred
dollars they're gonna give you another
two or three hundred dollars of free
money to gamble with if you use the
promo code bootleg all right mybookie.ag
head over there right now sign up for an
account so much to gamble on right now
we got NFL we got NBA baseball's over
baseball's trash who gives a [ __ ] NFL
NBA and I think hockey's going on
college football's going on college
basketball is going on what are we
[ __ ] doing let's get this money
mybookie.ag go sign up use the promo
code bootleg right now and they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars let's get back to the
interview
maybe like from what I know about like
13 people wow portraits that's funny
male and female male and it's just you
know what I'm saying it's just
impressive dude yeah yeah no I feel like
it's pretty dope it's cool I was kind of
surprised when I started first seeing
them yeah when you saw the first one did
it like freak you out a little or was it
like I said no way and I started
refreshing the page I'm like what no
[ __ ] way bro and then I started
refreshing it some more I was like no
hell no and I was like okay this is
really lit and then after the fourth
fifth one it's like okay cool dope
thanks for joining the team [ __ ] so
someone gets the face tattoo do they
just get like free concert tickets or I
embrace them for sure like anybody or is
it also they might be like a little
crazy no I'm not you never know man I
don't know uh I feel like no I embrace
them just as much as I do anybody else
bro you know what I'm saying listen if
someone gets a bootleg cab face tattoo
I'm I might block them and run because
I'm an ugly [ __ ] man
that's a questionable human being yeah
what the [ __ ] I mean you you know you're
you're you've got great music I just
[ __ ] talk [ __ ] for a living so yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no good looking out
bro no yeah I mean honestly I just
embrace them like anybody else what's
been the like most craziest spot they've
got in the tattoo
um
maybe like right above like like a girl
getting it like right above like right
here really that's about as crazy as it
got there's a girl who's got your face
over her vagina like kinda like yeah not
something yeah but yeah so when she
wears a bikini your face is right she is
some you know she's summertime she going
out there you know what I'm saying how
does your lady feel about that I feel
like in the beginning she was weirded
out like what like she kind of got a
little weirded out and irritated but
does she have your face tattooed on her
she has my name okay but not your face
not my face
this [ __ ] got your face on what is
going on
nah she has mine she has my name but no
no face though did you meet that girl
have you met her in person yeah I met
pretty much all of them I met like
nine of them the other ones I haven't
met in person wow you know where would
you say like obviously Southern
California is probably
your biggest Market yeah in terms of
fans outside of the State of California
where do you notice the love coming from
the most
I would say Cali I get a lot of love
it's weird I check my analytics I get a
lot of love from like uh Japan uh we got
some people in Australia it's out of the
country and then you got some New York
fans
some Seattle fans they're all over the
place right but more so I feel like my
cult following is like Cali for show
like outside of L.A what's is it like
Bakersfield oh oh [ __ ] says no like
where where are they [ __ ] with you
San Diego
San Diego Oceanside and then if you take
it up north a little bit it's like
Azalea and like the bear like Zach and
then like San Francisco and then I think
I've seen some Oakland yeah Oceanside is
a Vibe Oceanside is lit man get the fish
tacos go on the beach kick it it's fine
you kind of like look like you could be
Desi hollow's brother
that might have been like three percent
racist what I just said but you guys
look like you guys at least could like
be from the same like Hood cousins yeah
low keep [ __ ] if you look at if you look
at that nigga's face
he kind of looks a little like Asian a
little bit you know what I'm saying like
with that you know he might be I mean
listen I'm not speculating about
anyone's race as a white guy so I was
gonna say if he's from Oceanside dude
there's a lot of uh like Islanders in
[ __ ] he looks like Islander Vibes me
when you see me I kind of got this Aztec
nose [ __ ] I'm like you feel me we so
but that's the hair [ __ ] and that's the
skin tone that's about it right right
right we so different but I like that
[ __ ] though he's tight yeah nice guy
yeah he's cool I saw you worked with
sugar-free how was that he's [ __ ]
crazy he's a wild [ __ ] yeah he's
ridiculous he's like he's he's out there
he's a he's dope but he's out there yeah
I've heard that about him like he's just
like a sh like I wouldn't say
you know like when you meet certain
artists you're like oh you're out there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
really himself yeah when I uh I only met
him once and this was like 2010 and he
was walking through the Planet Hollywood
in Vegas with two [ __ ] on leashes
what yeah and I was like well this is
great this is exactly what I'd hoped to
see when sugar-free walked by me [ __ ]
nuts that's crazy yeah no he's crazy to
work with and [ __ ] he's got a lot of
energy he's always like plant like it's
it's just he's wild bro he's wild how
was he a big influence on you at all
when I was younger I like dodoing a
skunk yeah what else did I [ __ ] would I
[ __ ] with uh all of his [ __ ] man like so
what you going doing what you want to
get like you'd rather give you my [ __ ]
he was Monumental to me when I was
younger him and Snoop Dogg and [ __ ] like
so working with him was like a dream bro
it's crazy like just even like he
reached out he's like yeah let's do it
we got a project dropping on the 23rd
four or five songs just me and him
that's fire so yeah he you know he's
like a he's like an older crazy or me to
a certain degree you know what I'm
saying except for you're in a committed
relationship and I mean he's married now
do you know do you know that why that
[ __ ] did that I feel like because of me
oh really I influenced that [ __ ] to
settle down I influenced you sugar-free
you don't gotta admit that [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you you big bro but I've been
kicking around you and he was like man I
I just settled down life might be great
this is kind of cool I don't want to
give you my [ __ ] anymore I want to keep
her for myself I'd rather keep my [ __ ]
I'm not gonna share anymore yeah God
yeah yeah no I think I influenced that
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] because I would
talk to the [ __ ] on the phone for two
three hours and he'd just be he's a he's
a good he's a good guy though sugar-free
shout out sugar free do you notice
people comparing you to Nipsey a lot
yeah
this is what this is the thing when I
make certain songs yeah you could hear
it somewhat but the the difference
between me and Nipsey because I love
Nipsey of course of course [ __ ]
Legend but I'm saying the difference
between me and Nipsey is like I feel
like I got a whole diverse just area of
different sounds and Pockets I can go to
right I got this but when you're in your
[ __ ] I feel like I hear it yeah and it's
not a bad thing yeah like it doesn't
feel like it I'm not saying that in a
negative way but yeah yeah oh this guy
might [ __ ] around be the new Nipsey
right right in the same way when nipsy
first came out Snoop everybody said he
was this is just Snoop Dogg but skinnier
and and lighter lighter yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but I think like I feel like sometimes
when I hear some of your [ __ ] like you
said when you get in certain pockets and
you're really on your like La [ __ ] I'm
like oh yeah I hear it man oh yeah
screaming and hollering all that [ __ ] I
get that all the time Nipsey they'll be
like uh nipsy from wish Nipsey 2.0 like
[ __ ] I'll be like yeah wish me like I'm
like [ __ ] come on bro but yeah I
appreciate that I take it as a
compliment as you should man hey we
gotta stop the interview man to tell you
about our good Folks at Blue chew baby
that's right make sure you go to
bluetooth.com uh and use the promo code
bootleg yeah because what happens at
bluetooth.com is you get the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but
it's delivered right to your door in a
discreet package no doctor's
appointments involved fellas yo it's
getting cold as [ __ ] and you got that
dick you're trying to lay on a lovely
lady consensually of course all right
you might as well make sure you show up
to the party with all the [ __ ]
HGH uh you know uh performance enhancing
uh situations you can have you really
just need to pop a single blue shoe and
you're [ __ ] out there man you're
gonna have the hardest [ __ ] you've ever
had in your life alright so listen go to
Bluetooth
and uh use the promo code bootleg
because you get your first month for
free so go to bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg you get a whole month for free
try it out
okay try it out with that promo code
bootleg and don't forget they just
dropped their mint flavored chewable
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so that means it's
a little bit more pep in your step you
go to the mint you go to Old School
Bluetooth whatever it is you're gonna be
[ __ ] bud for sure you're gonna wake
up in the morning with the hardest [ __ ]
you've ever had in your life all right
I promise that's Cyrus he just takes him
and jerks off in his bedroom
he's got Bluetooth Fridays in his house
everyone's out there working Cyrus the
producer he eats a Bluetooth he turns
the surround sound on he's got the
[ __ ] PornHub going and he's just
beating his dick like it stole something
anyway bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
and you get a free month of blue chew
right now going to sign up and [ __ ]
help us out because you know what I'm
saying we trying to get this money too
all right bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
yeah yeah taking it so when you say
you're making a rock project what kind
of rock are we talking about it's rappy
Rock it's like Limp Biscuit Fred Durst
Limp Biscuit but it's more so [ __ ] I'm
a [ __ ] so I got the gang bang in there a
little bit I twisted it up you know what
I'm saying we dressing up me and Still's
going crazy with that shout out to
steals great guys shout out Stills man
he's a sweet kid he's a good kid he's
also a grown up he's a nice little kid
he's a grown man they're a nice kid
Stills is a grown-up
I feel like I've known him for like 10
years he's a nice gentleman yeah yeah
he's a nice gentleman
and he loves designer so much he got it
tattooed on his body good grades in
school nice boy no I love stuff now you
guys have developed like a dope uh just
working relationship in in terms of like
I feel like
steals has been on a run as well as
yourself yes you guys you know doing
joint projects and [ __ ] together
definitely definitely do you feel like
it's a difference when you go that
approach and you lock in solely with
like a Steals and when you do
just different producers oh yeah for
sure is it Stills I'm in there with the
[ __ ] cooking up the magic making it we
laughing giggling my order some chicken
wings or something like that with other
producers it's like yeah send me a pack
bro bet I'm over there bamboo it's done
I can create that from scratch but
Stills though yeah you know what I'm
saying which one do you prefer
Stills yeah steals over anybody honestly
because we just get in there and we Just
Vibe like bro I need something with
pianos then I'll explain to the [ __ ]
what I want like I need something that's
gonna make me feel like Geppetto
swallowed as in a well stomach
and it's dark and I want to feel
evil
what does that sound like
or I'll tell the [ __ ] I want to be I
want to feel like I'm a lost Native
American Indian trying to find my tribe
while pilgrims and settlers are trying
to kill me [ __ ] just go go crazy
and he'll make the sound I'll be like
[ __ ] that's what I was looking for Wow
that's
[ __ ]
[ __ ] which which song is that is it out
it's not out it's not out yet we got
some [ __ ] [ __ ] we got some [ __ ] um
you know uh yeah I was he wasn't
expecting you see that [ __ ] just kind
of just was quiet right there
that's amazing I'm just in my head I'm
like how does that what does that sound
like getting swallowed by a whale yeah
sounds like I'm a dice you are familiar
with the Pinocchio story though uh dude
I I you got kids though a kid lied and
he grew a nose and he's not a real boy
and there was dude I [ __ ] was not a
Pinocchio guy I was watching Lion King
and
and um I feel these Tarzan and [ __ ] I
saw you just posted a [ __ ] love photo
with Tarzan
that's the one thing about me I'm always
just myself as you should be I'm just
and it's a lot I know it's a lot of
people like I'll meet some of these
rappers and recording artists and when
when you meet them like right for the
first time it's like
what's up bro yeah we gotta work
yeah hell yeah my [ __ ] I just been
chilling you hit my line bro yeah and
then when I really start to chop it up
with these [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] my favorite
Pokemon when I was younger was
it's like okay that's the real Yuka
that's the real you you know what I'm
saying it's like [ __ ] got this facade
about them and it's like when you break
Beyond it it's like damn could just be
you just do you you know I'm saying if
you like Disney [ __ ] if you like
Teletubbies [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if
you like putting on red wigs and be a
clown my [ __ ] do you bro you you gonna
be alone in that casket
um
yeah no I mean I see it all the time
you'll see like he'll meet a rapper and
you'll be like all right you got your
[ __ ] rapper Persona going right now
it's always a thing you know what I'm
saying it's crazy especially La guys
like if they're around their homies and
[ __ ] and it's like a rapper environment
you're like oh God we get it like bro I
understand you got 17 [ __ ] with you
[ __ ] have face tattoos you got the
same shirt on the chains I get it you're
you're slouching your pants sagging on
your ass my [ __ ] I will beat you up
like I'll beat you up for real
and I'll put on and I'll put on
Pinocchio at home with my girlfriend I
was gonna say I do feel like what's dope
about you is that it feels like you're
really kind of like
you know a lot of La artists like
they're a part of cruise or they're kind
of like really intertwined in the
industry as to where I kind of feel like
you're just kind of on your own Island
just making [ __ ] happen pretty much bro
it's it's it's all fictitious factions
that they create it's personas it's it's
cool if you have a manager uh I do okay
yeah I do have is that new
um you know what's so funny
my manager kind of doesn't want to be
known as my manager right now you know
what I'm saying but it's like a Gentry
it's a secret no Gentry's not my man
okay no Gentry's my boy though Gentry
guy yeah yeah no Gentry's my [ __ ] yeah
but no Gentry is not my manager um it's
another cat though but yeah Gentry kind
of helps out he throws me little plays
here and they're like hey you should do
this you should do this I love Gentry
okay yeah I didn't know because I was
like yo like if it feels like when you
do your merch [ __ ] I'm like yo is this
guy just doing this by himself I pretty
pretty much yeah is your girl help a lot
kinda most of the time she's just we
just you know yeah just arguing yeah and
loving each other and having sex and
waking up do you feel like sometimes
you'll fight just for the makeup sex
uh no I haven't been that toxic but I
have do you think she's that toxic
though or should be like
just what is this and then you never
know yeah you never know right you never
know she might go to the store buy a
condom rip this [ __ ] open put a cucumber
in it
[ __ ] uh pull it out of the trash can
randomly and then just start to fight
with me and try to fight who knows and
then have makeup sex that's a wild wild
thing that just girls are crazy yeah she
hasn't done that yet don't get any ideas
what's her ethnicity she's Japanese and
Mexican oh that's the that's the one-two
punch bud man I'm telling you we got we
got we got Tapatio on the sushi at home
you haven't tried that yet have you I
mean because my wife's Mexican and I've
dated Asians
and lots of Latin women oh yeah
those are the two that you don't [ __ ]
with oh no [ __ ] no you're in the dead
she turned up on me a couple times yeah
swung at me I had to back up I'm like
damn [ __ ] you know how to do Jiu Jitsu
or something yeah it's crazy yeah for
I've never dated a white woman but I
always hear that white women are the uh
they're the most gullible uh and like
relaxed
they are for sure probably
I've never dated a white woman either
but I know that white white girls are
chill as [ __ ] probably I I guess I don't
know I mean I could just I could just
picture it [ __ ] I come home from a show
we live in Santa Barbara somewhere by
the ocean hey honey do you want do you
want me to make you some you know what I
mean
probably got Sugar Ray someday plant or
something like that she's
[Laughter]
the Sugar Ray you know what I'm saying
I'm in there now you know Zan he's she's
frying up some tofu and quinoa zucchini
or something and
I mean [ __ ] [ __ ] uh yeah Dawson's
Creek is playing I don't [ __ ] yeah
that's trigger right oh my goodness no
worries [ __ ] no worries man hey what up
y'all we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our folks at
hardean Las Vegas you see them right
there you know I mean shout out to hard
D Man shout out to everybody over there
it's the uh illest dispensary in the
world number one they got the craziest
selection of weed you'll ever go to when
you're in Las Vegas there's only one
place to go that's hard in you pull up
you say hey I heard about this place on
the bootleg cat podcast and they're
gonna get you hooked up with some
[ __ ] weed all right so go to Jardin
Las Vegas right now if you're in the
city of uh sin or you're going make sure
you uh you know put it put together a
little hour off to the side to make sure
you go get your nice [ __ ] Harding bag
full of uh just a premium weed all right
and not only that you gotta shoot them a
follow Harding underscore Las Vegas I'm
gonna shout them out though because
Harding smells the best the dispensary
is just it's not only the best
dispensary in the world it's the best
smelling dispensary in the world and
look now the bootleg kit podcast smells
like Jardin because I have the hardine
signature scent candle you could have
one too you could go to [ __ ] Hardy in
Las Vegas just saying also make sure you
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas that is important you have to
follow them because there's some
[ __ ] accounts out there we
appreciate hard Dean when you're in
Vegas pull up go get you some smoke go
get you some edibles go get you some
[ __ ] carts whatever it is they got it
and they got it at the highest quality
it's the only place I'm smoking from
that's Hardy in Las Vegas let's get back
to the interview what inspired you to do
some rock music though was it just like
this is the [ __ ] I like I want to try it
I love rock music bro alternative rock
Pennywise sugary like I said before
um I love Pennywise all kind of um
Nickelback I love you have Nickelback
blink 182. God Nickelback so gay
[ __ ] I love I even like of course AC DC
[ __ ] Nirvana The White Stripes yeah
White Stripes choir this is all good
bands look Nickelback's got hits I
forgot as my friend jelly roll says
Nickelback still [ __ ] their music [ __ ]
I love rock bro country I [ __ ] a country
too yeah I like country Bryant uh I like
what's is that the fat guy what's the
fat guy Luke Combs Luke Combs he's funny
yeah um um [ __ ] Luke Combs what song did
he don't tell me um
um some things go better together
I like the one about the long neck cold
beer never broke my heart oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah Better Together by Luke Combs
is hard too though and um
a lot of people like Morgan Wallen I
don't know who the [ __ ] that is he's the
guy who did the song with little Dirk oh
see he's one of them type of [ __ ] he
like not a real country [ __ ] he's like
a he is he oh for real but he's but he's
still [ __ ] with that rap shot he grew
up like listening to like you know and
then there's like guys like jelly roll
who make country but they came from the
right I like jelly roll I don't know I
don't I can't name a song
great guy jelly roll is cool yeah super
good guy uh what else do you got coming
besides the rock project the sugar-free
project sugar-free project we're doing
like a lover boy project
um some rock we might do we might do
some country but we might do a country
rap project [ __ ] I'm just trying to
[ __ ] just get all that hit all the
Avenues of the the [ __ ] that I like jazz
we might [ __ ] around with that I'm just
trying to mix it all the way up I'm not
just trying to stay in one pocket I
wanna have fun how do you think your
fans would react to you doing a country
album
this is the thing
it's one thing to stick to your cult
following and give them what they want
and feed them what they need which I
always will and then there's one thing
to venture out and do things for
yourself and just see what other avenues
are out there for yourself musically
right you feel what I'm saying and you
drop at such a high rate that even if
you put something out that you're like
cult fans are like what the [ __ ] you'll
be like don't worry I got your [ __ ]
coming don't worry I'm gonna throw the
Dickie suit on [ __ ] I'm I'm yeah I'm
still here you feel me I might bring out
the guitar with the straw hat but then
they gotta throw that [ __ ] right away
and [ __ ] jump right into the converse
[ __ ] yo I wanted to talk to you because
you know there's this culture in La
where there's artists who will come out
here they'll have big homies out here
but they're not from here right yeah and
um you'll see like a situation like a
um I'm sure you saw what happened with
quando Rondo yeah quote-unquote dropped
the flag pretty much yeah said he's
because because I think he was was he
banging rolling 60s I think so yeah I
think he was from 60s yeah um his friend
died obviously he was going through it
you know yeah um but you know I know
that that's
I mean certain people will look at that
and be like good for him other people
would be like what the [ __ ] you know
like
this did
this the thing right like no matter how
far I go no matter where I go no matter
what I do I'll give a [ __ ] if I just got
a song with Lady Gaga if she's still
relevant yeah of course she's Lady Gaga
She'll always yeah yeah I know so if I
had a song with Lady Gaga and I blew up
and I had the most money in the world
or not even that that tube or if I'm in
a car and three of my homies get smoked
right in front of me right I'm a [ __ ]
until I go to until I'm done it's just
it's just that's it's not it's like a
fraternity like you if you in [ __ ]
college and you're from Alpha Phi Alpha
even when you graduate and you get your
job at the end of it my [ __ ] is 78
years old or 80 years old you're still
gonna have your colors you're still
gonna have your logo you're still gonna
pull up to those meetings so [ __ ] any
[ __ ] that stop banging
I really don't condone it you know like
actively like actively being in the
street and gang banging and fighting and
killing and [ __ ] like okay [ __ ] stop
that you feel me right right grow and
evolve and metamorphosize but to just
drop your flag no yeah yeah you can't
drop your flag yeah because I feel like
like you were saying like you want to
grow you don't want to always be in the
streets but that doesn't mean that
you're gonna disown where you come from
at the same time exactly exactly that's
fair you know what I'm saying
yeah sure
um what do you think about if you had to
give advice to people coming to LA
because all we do is see people getting
robbed on on social media now this is
something that has always happened out
here since the pandemic since the PPP
and the EDD has dried up I feel like
yeah it's escalated and now there's
social media so we see it a lot more but
how would you advise people to move
around out here just to kind of like in
general like on some like on some Street
[ __ ] yeah or even just like if you're
some [ __ ]
you know people are just I always tell
people
don't wear no [ __ ] jewelry yeah it's
really worth it like you know what's so
crazy um it's funny I'm glad you said
that I got a project coming out top of
January it's called the LA handbook
everything that you're asking me it's
crazy I'm so glad you said that because
I got a seven track project with steals
it's called La handbook and it's from
one through seven telling you what to do
and what not to do
hey we gotta stop the interview to tell
you about our family at odd sucks that's
right the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world go to
oddsocksofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsoxofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview you know leave the
sprinters at home if you can get a Prius
get like four or five Priuses
um take the chains off [ __ ] put the
chains under there tap in with some
[ __ ] that really got some pool in the
city whether it be the neighborhood
[ __ ] The Gangsta [ __ ] the Bloods
essays whatever you got to do make sure
that you tap and pay your dudes because
that's the that's the type of culture
that we got out here if you ain't
banging
uh cause [ __ ] will get you man well
anything else in the LA handbook that's
important
um
so far just the sprinters and the chains
um definitely
watch out what hat you're wearing watch
what hat you're wearing don't come out
here flagging that out of town [ __ ]
unless you tapped in with the like say
you from I'm gonna just make up Hood
because I don't want to say anybody's
Hood like say with some [ __ ] called
42nd Street villains you know let's just
you y'all [ __ ] know where I'm getting
at 42nd Street villains and you from the
Seattle Branch don't come to California
just thinking that you know oh I'm from
42nd Street villains out there I should
be good out here no you gotta tap in
with the 42nd Street villains in
California make sure that your Thuggin
is right and your politics is right
before you move around because [ __ ] you
could be over for you you could pull up
to your show and get [ __ ] up
could you bypass everything
by just checking in with Swifty blue
[Laughter]
[ __ ] was about to come up man would you
go online you could just you could print
the certificate right and shout out to
Swifty great guy I love Swifty I just
I'm just curious Swifty is a [ __ ] is
a genius genius of that was the best
because like once the website went up
and like you could print a certificate I
was like oh this guy's a [ __ ] genius
he's done he's done no he's [ __ ]
intelligent no obviously [ __ ] you got
to tap him with the right people but
Swifty might be I don't know like I'm
not a southsider so right and I got
respect for Southsiders I'm half Mexican
so some of my family members are
Southsiders um but that's not my
politics so I wouldn't know what to know
how to yeah I wouldn't know how to go
about that and I got nothing but love
and respect for the South Side um but me
I run my program with the Crips so shout
out to you man well look uh so much new
music coming
uh
um what's the next thing is it the
sugar-free thing the sugar-free thing uh
we got La handbook we got some rock [ __ ]
coming out
um more business ventures man you know
we got uh water collabs we got all kind
of [ __ ] crackers what other business
ventures you got your hands in right now
man
um definitely the water collapse I just
had Genie in a Bottle that was my that
was my my um my drink that has spirulina
in it it was fresh it's full of
antioxidants it's good for you
um it's all blue and [ __ ] because I'm a
crib you got that
um the clothing there's just so many
avenues that we're I'm exploring right
now at this point entrepreneurial wise
you know as opposed to just just being a
[ __ ] rapper is boring any shows
coming up definitely definitely next
year top of next year we got something
coming but don't have the dates yet have
you done the uh have you headlined the
rocks yet I haven't headlined the Roxy
yet it's about that time for you to do
that [ __ ] got to get it going my
management [ __ ] up like that [ __ ] he
would sell that [ __ ] out in three days
for sure quick for sure ASAP I feel like
every up and coming lar is they gotta
have their Roxy moments you have to to
yeah if you don't then it's like all
right [ __ ] can you go do the
Observatory yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah this [ __ ] gonna be crazy bro we're
gonna get it going yeah go up north you
know everything yeah oh yeah yellow Hill
appreciate you pulling up Brother come
on man bootleg Kev I appreciate you yes
sir boom bam